[Music]
okay thank you I teach a course biology
101 and last fall it enrolled 220
students this big group of people here
is as large as many classes at Yale
College these are just the instructors
for the course it's two professors and
twelve teaching fellows and together we
are grading and providing feedback on
3000 assignments the students hand in
during this course and this is
logistically daunting and we use canvas
as our organizing tool to get us through
this one of the simplest things that we
use canvas for is just just distribute
course materials to the students so here
in this files function we've loaded up a
whole bunch of folders of materials so
lecture notes for every lecture a study
guide for every lecture all of the
reading assignments students go in here
download everything electronically
there's a hundred and eighty megabytes
of materials that students can download
in these folders I want to focus on our
homework assignments so students go into
the assignments tool they pull up a
homework assignment they get information
on it including when it's due the date
and the time they click on this link
they download the assignment as an
electronic document and then they fill
in their answers to the questions
electronically they go to this screen
they select the file on their computer
they submit it and that uploads the
completed assignment and then our very
favorite feature for this class of
canvas is speed grader which was
mentioned earlier so the Teaching Fellow
goes in just gets a list of the students
in their section whose work they're
grading they don't need to download the
files for those assignments they just
click on the student and we get this
preview window which shows the contents
of that homework assignment and now
using these tools the Teaching Fellow
can go in and start marking up the
assignment they can write you got five
points on question one here the student
wrote something that wasn't quite right
the Teaching Fellow makes a note here
telling the student something at the end
they can say great work on this
assignment and then they
and a score here and that automatically
goes into the grades function they click
Submit and they're done and I just want
to emphasize we never downloaded
anything we never uploaded anything and
when you had 213 assignments to go
through that's a huge time savings those
scores that we enter automatically go
into the grades function which creates
this ginormous spreadsheet and I know
you can't read the details but just to
point out how this works every row is a
student every column is an assignment
and then we've got a final score here at
the end and so here we're viewing all
the students in the course but a
Teaching Fellow could just pull up
records for the students in their
section when we set this up at the
beginning of the semester we assigned a
point value or a percentage value for
every assignment and then this system
can automatically take those values into
account and calculate a final score and
we use a complex grading scheme in this
course so for example there are five
homework assignments and the students
are allowed to drop the score for their
lowest scored homework assignment and
perhaps you can see here in these first
five columns for every student one of
the scores is grayed out and that's the
one that canvas automatically determined
was the lowest score and it got dropped
from the final calculation we can see
here the scores for every student in the
class the students the individual
students can see their own scores that
we've entered and there's another
function that we love so here's the
detail from the grades feature we pull
up specific details about an assignment
and while we're entering the scores and
proofreading and making sure we did
everything accurately we mute the
assignment so the students can't see
when we by mistake we entered an
incorrect score when we've determined
that we've entered everything correctly
we can go in and unmute the assignment
and now for the final exam all of the
grades are released to the students at
the same time when we have three
thousand scores that we have to enter we
want to make sure we don't make a
mistake and because the students can see
their own scores they make sure that
we've entered everything correctly we
often communicate with our students by
email and canvas
automatically interfaces with the
registrar's computer so it makes these
email lists here one for every student
in the course so we can blast an email
to everybody but also automatically set
up our email lists for each one of the
thirteen sections discussion sections in
the course so the Teaching Fellow
leading a section can click on one of
those and communicate just with the
students in their section there's a new
tool that was beta tested this year that
we use called sign up that we used to
set up office hours and we like like
that tool so here we are I decide that
I've got three hours available tomorrow
when I could meet with students I go in
to sign up I tell that I'm available
from 12:00 to 3:00 I decide that I'm
gonna set up half hour time slot so it
divides it there I decide that I'm
willing to see one student at a time
so I set that up now we have a little
menu I say okay canvas automatically
emails all the students in the course
and says hey professor Cole's available
from 12:00 to 3:00 tomorrow and there's
some new slots available they go in here
click on one of those that sets up an
appointment there's then an itinerary
that I can see on canvas of all the
students were coming at specific times
and they show up in my office we also
use this to set up lunch as I have lunch
with a group of five students at a time
every Wednesday after lecture you can
set up a slot here that lets five
students sign up for that time and it
takes care of all the logistics large
courses they can be impersonal you'd
like to be able to have one-on-one
interactions with the students and this
really facilitates that okay thank you
and I'll take questions
[Applause]
in the sign-up section are those slots
blinded so other students couldn't see I
believe so so the student just sees that
a slot is available I can see who's
coming but they can't see the other
students you can't choose that as an
option though if you wanted to allow
students to swap spots you have the
choice to determine whether or not they
will see it I have a question but not
for you for the technician I we used to
a great students homework online on
canvas but because it's written in
Chinese so now for some reason this
semester we cannot see their responses
all just boxes instead of characters
yeah last year it worked well but this
year we cannot just you know grade it on
campus we have to download it and then
upload so that sounds like a bug send us
an email at canvas at Yale and we can
work with because we have contacts at
campus structure which is a company that
created canvas and we can work with them
to find out why these things are going
wrong so the more people who give us
examples of courses where this is
failing the more they'll they will have
you know something to dig into and
research to find out why this is
happening and fix it any other questions
[Applause]
[Music]